I'm here with ayaan Hirsi Ali human
rights activist and author of the new
book heretic why Islam needs a
reformation now I and welcome to the
show thank you thank you Dave thank you
for having me on so I'm gonna show all
my cards right up front here I'm such a
huge admirer of yours and I think you
you've done such good work and your
story's amazing and your bravery is
amazing so I'm gonna hold nothing back
and just set us off on that on that good
welcoming note is that okay with you
thank you thank you for having me on
again and thank you for everything you
said so there's a ton that I want to
talk to you about and so many of the
things that your life is an example of
are the things that we've been talking
about on the show here for months now
and I know many of my guests have been
people that you're you're friends with
and co-workers with and have done
speeches with but your story is the most
unique and most interesting and I want
to talk about the book but I thought we
could just spend about 10 minutes just
sort of on your biography and I know
you've discussed it a lot and that's
what one of the books is about but if
you it's so illuminating to sort of how
you got here so if you can just tell me
a little bit first about growing up in
Somalia and let's just start with that
well I was born into Somali Muslim
household and if I look at my journey
from I was born in 1969 November my
family went to Saudi Arabia we lived in
Ethiopia we lived in Kenya and then I
went to the Netherlands and now I live
in the United States of America I think
if you look at my geographical journey
it is really nothing unique about it
today people from all over the world
moved to different places learn
different languages and adapt to
different situations I think that what
Westerners find interesting intriguing
and maybe in some ways disconcerting is
the intellectual journey I was raised as
a Muslim I was raised in a clan or
tribal society and the moral framework
that prevails there is
that of honor and shame and it's a
different kind of honor and shame from
what we believe here in the West which
is you know as a little girl at the age
of five my genitals were cut and when I
was old enough to ask why did that
happen
my grandmother was very you know she
readily explained it as well we purified
you and if you are not purified you will
never find a husband so that kind of
practice is and it isn't something that
happened only to me it happened to and
it happens according to United Nations
numbers to 98 percent of Somalis
Egyptians Sudanese and so that's one
thing that people find fascinating how
could you have endured something like
that and come out of a cultural context
like that and then fast forward when I'm
22 years old my father returns from a
long journey he was he had left us for
10 years in Kenya a country that if you
are a Somali you feel you know you are
in a foreign country and comes back and
he feels he has the right it as my
father to marry me off to the first
suitor the first guy who comes along and
says you know I'm off the same plan as
you I'm looking for a wife which girl
would you like to offer and then I'm the
one who's offered so to Westerners that
seems pretty strange yeah and is this
person just to be clear this person was
a distant cousin reviewer's right which
probably wasn't that abnormal for that
area absolutely not in fact the closer
the kinship the better because the only
way to make sure that family members are
loyal to one another share wealth don't
mistreat one another is to try and marry
within the same family as much as
possible obviously with all the
genetical problems but that's not what
we were looking at but that is that's
the context you know your your roles as
a male as a as a female that's given as
a female you can bring shame not only on
your father and mother your brother and
sister but the extended family as well
and even the extended religion and so I
what is fascinating for most Westerners
is how could you that intellectual
journey how come once I believed in all
that I lived it and now
I'm saying you know as an individual you
have a right to be free to choose who
you want to marry you don't have to cut
off the genitals of girls for them to be
married you don't even have to be
married if you don't want to because as
an economic security as a woman in the
Western context whether is the rule of
Lord where is freedom where this is
wonderful education systems as ago you
can actually choose you know what you
want to do in life you can map out your
own destiny
yeah and that that's why I love your
story so much and why I find you so
inspirational because you're you're
truly living breathing proof that things
can change and that people and and girls
especially from this part of the world
can have a different life and that's why
I find it so wonderful but let's just
back up for just a second on the female
genital mutilation when when this
happened to you
did you immediately and you spoke to
your grandmother and all this but did
you immediately question everything I to
be that age and go through something
like that how long did it take before
you really were questioning everything
about your life at the age of five I
didn't question it at the age of ten I
didn't question anything at the age of
20 but I didn't question anything but
there's always as you grow up and I
remember for me in terms of evolving as
you're evolving from childhood to
maturity
it was the ages of 14 15 16 when I want
to know you know what's the point of
this life and why are we put on earth
and is it only to reproduce we are you
know at that point my family I we're
going through a lot of adversity and it
is what is the point what is the point
so instead of being suicidal I joined
the Muslim Brotherhood because they make
the points so very clear you've been put
on this earth to be by God to be tested
for your absolute submission you're
going to be tested as a female in
various ways and as a male in various
ways and you just have to say yes to
that submit and
on your points and for your audience I'm
just going to give you one interesting
way in which how do they how does one
even manipulate that as a believing
Muslim how does one know that you know
you're doing what God wants you to do
you have two angels on either side of
your shoulders when your height side you
have an angel that notes down minute by
minute second by second your good
intentions versus your bad intentions so
we're not here we're not even talking
about what you say it's really before
you say but on top of that that same
angel also notes down what you say and
then your behavior and on your left
same thing everything that you do that
is wrong that angel is doing the
bookkeeping and you live and at some
points you die and then there is the
hereafter there is the day of judgment
and we are told as Muslims no one can
escape that your God and his tribunal
you before God and his tribunal the
prophets the angels and all these other
human beings and those two books are
going to be put on a scale and if you
write handbook weighs heavier than your
left hand book you go to heaven and if
your left hand book goes weighs heavier
you go to hell and you know as you grow
up
it's expecially with you know the
radical Islam ization of all things
these things are made so explicit to you
and you become so aware of them it's
like in the West it's like taking
keeping track of your calories yeah yeah
well it's interesting because even the
way you're describing it there's sort of
a whimsical nough stew the way you're
describing it because now as a secular
person it sounds so ridiculous to you
and yet there's there's literally
millions of people that believe in this
in a literal sense absolutely absolutely
and you know you're young you trust your
parents your teachers you and Islam is
your religion and religion I mean I know
all human beings who are religious are
taught that the criteria you know the
framework how do we know the difference
between what's right and what's wrong
religion tells us that and so as a
Muslim in Islam is a way of life you are
taught that this is the difference
between right and wrong
and these things are spelled out that
which is forbidden Haram that which is
permitted hallow and so then it's up to
you there's a level of there's a level
of choice in there you know right it
sounds like it sounds like the guy on
your shoulder already knows your
intentions anyway right exactly so even
if you abstain they still ain't no
stealing knows you want to indulge well
all right so I want to talk a lot about
I want to talk it's funny that it seems
funny to you now I'm glad to see that
and you have a beautiful smile so it's
nice because you've come out of this so
it really is nice so I just want to do
one more thing on your bio and then we
can we can get into some of the
specifics about the doctrine and things
sort of in your life after that so you
you made political asylum in the
Netherlands you then became Member of
Parliament this is an incredible story
of success and you know with all the the
refugee things going on in Europe right
now there's a lot of parallels to that
you found safety and became successful
and influential and went on to talk
about female genital mutilation and
women's rights and all this incredible
stuff but here of course I have to
mention that then Theo van Gogh was
doing a movie based on a script that you
wrote and he was killed by a Muslim
extremist in broad daylight in Amsterdam
at 9:00 a.m. in the morning and as if
that wasn't horrific enough the the
person that killed him pinned a death
threat to you on this person's body now
I know I know you've talked about this a
lot and I know people hear things like
this and I don't think it quite gets to
them you know it sounds like a movie
sort of right and so I just want you to
talk about a little bit about it
specifically but also just the feeling
that it left you with the sort of terror
because it's one thing to say these
things happen but you're you're a person
that these things actually happen to
well in a way I have to say the
difference between a Theo van Gogh and
myself was that I lived in those threats
I didn't know exactly what the
individuals who were threatening me
would do so two years prior to Theo's
death I started to take all kinds of
security precautions and when he and I
were working together I kept saying here
you know I know it sounds surreal in a
Dutch context I think he would tell me
over and over again do you know the last
time in the Netherlands someone was
killed because of what they believed in
and he would give me years from the 17th
century
like we're Dutch this is the Netherlands
we don't do that sort of thing so relax
let's do this and that was actually true
because because Holland was an
incredible place of mixed cultures and
religions and ethnicities and all that
right absolutely it was and it wasn't
only that it was also in you know the
wider Europe when in hundreds of years
ago to 17th century 18th century when on
religious grounds
people would face intolerance so much as
to threaten their lives thinkers
creative people they would go to the
Netherlands and they would get a
sanctuary and so for him it was for fear
it making this film it wasn't about that
yeah it was about preserving what he
knew was his culture his civilization
and and really not just Dutch
civilization I think civilization with a
capital C when human beings can discuss
and can disagree without having to
threaten with force right so in a
bizarre way by by them killing him
instead of you in a in a weird I know
this sounds perverse er sighing but that
was more of a direct attack on Holland
right because they were going after one
of their own
so to speak so to speak and I I had I
had accepted the perimeters that the
government puts me within you know a
security framework which was it really
is something that the theo van gogh said
i
never ever accept anything like that
because these security measures curtail
your freedom to a degree that you're not
free and I'm never going to accept that
and and he wanted to prove to them it is
not having to you know put a shell
around the people who are practicing
free speech that is not the answer
the answer is to openly discuss these
things and make them open if these
people are provoked by what is that was
that particular film was this is what
the Quran says about women this is how
it's put into practice that's what we
need to be talking about we shouldn't be
talking about security and he gets
killed and I think by doing the murderer
killed Theo van Gogh and that incident
confronted Dutch society and Dutch
leadership and I think the wider
European Western leadership with you
know we can all go around saying talking
about the First Amendment freedom of
speech freedom of expression all this
that and the other but what are we
willing to do to preserve it he he has
left us with that question and I'm
disappointed to say that so far we
haven't done that much because as you
know this year the beginning of this
year the cartoonists in Paris were
killed and the threats to free speech
continues and if government policies are
anything to go by it seems as if they
are telling us it's best not to provoke
them yeah all right so I really want to
focus on that because that's been one of
the you know this free speech and
political correctness it's become this
perfect storm that's actually
strengthening everything that it should
be against but just to put a final cap
on on your bio and all that what was it
like for you I mean really at the
personal level when he was killed did
you want to just disappear did you want
to leave the country did you want to
give up because now you've lived for
these last how many years ago was this
this was it's just new thousand not four
right so you've lived for these the last
eleven years honoring everything he
stood for but I'm sure there must have
been a time when you thought let me just
get out of this right well I think it
every day I think it all the time it's
so tempting to just think you know I've
done enough I'm this is my age I'm 46
years old next month
there's nothing for me in it personally
but it's I think it's what Hayek said
made the difference between being
comfortable which if I just disappeared
and changed my name I would be very
comfortable versus actually living which
is when you're challenged and when
civilization is challenged when our
freedoms are challenged we always rely
on those who stand up for it
and those who want to push their agenda
through intimidation through force they
know that their argument is very weak
otherwise why would they avoid
discussion why is it difficult for them
to showcase what the Quran and Allah and
hadith the sayings of the Prophet
Muhammad and the jurisprudence and the
practice of Islam say is about women and
says to women why are they afraid if
women all women had 100 percent the
freedom to choose and you know if your
message is superior why not keep why not
allow people to just choose for it